thank you very much
prime minister levine de stefan
ladies and gentlemen
i'm honored and i'm humbled to speak to
the malmo international forum on
holocaust remembrance
and combating anti-semitism
because today
our common fight against anti-semitism
is more urgent than ever
anti-semitism is on the rise across
europe
40 percent of jews say
they hide symbols that could identify
them
out of fear
of being physically attacked
and we've seen the terrorist attacks in
paris and brussels and copenhagen
and halle two years ago almost to the
day
so today my thoughts are also with the
victims and with the families who lost
their loved ones
but these attacks are also a stark
reminder
of how toxic anti-semitism is for our
society
and i therefore welcome the objective of
the malmo forum
to jointly pledge concrete actions to
fight anti-semitism
and to eradicate it
i am proud
that last week the commission adopted
the first ever
eu strategy on combating anti-semitism
and fostering jewish life
with this unprecedented step
we are pursuing three important goals
first
we want to strengthen and expand our
fight against anti-semitism
anti-semitism is a threat to jewish
people
but it is also a poison for our
democracies our values
and our open societies
we have to fight it offline and online
and hate speech disinformation and the
denial of facts
are everywhere online
the covered 19 pandemic has shown how
quickly conspiracy myth can spread
therefore with our digital services act
we make clear
that online platforms must take greater
responsibility every business especially
powerful tech giants
has to combat hatred
and to stand for historical truth
second
we want to foster jewish life in europe
in all its diversity
76 years after the holocaust
jewish life is thriving again in the
hearts of our communities
and we should be proud of this and make
it visible
among many other actions
we will for example ask those cities
aspiring to become european capital of
culture
to spotlight the contribution of jewish
life and culture in their city
we will also make sure that jews are
free to follow their religious
traditions
and we will increase funding to better
protect places of worship
all over in our union
and finally my third point
we promise to preserve the memory of
past atrocities
remembering the showa
is our shared responsibility
and as the last survivors are passing
away
we need to find new ways of remembering
and this is why
we will create a network of young
european ambassadors for holocaust
remembrance
because who is in a better position
to teach the lessons of the show to
their peers
than our young
so let me assure you
we will be ambitious when implementing
our new strategy
because europe can only prosper
if the jewish community is prospered too
so let's join forces
to make this happen
and i wish you a successful forum thank
you very much